ça va
en fait le dunga modelito de la dengue
ça choque la loi qui couvre la célébrité à la télé
déplacé et blessé yoga le pouvoir britannique
le pilote de l'équipe est revenu si c'était vraiment dedans
smile mode est le propriétaire d'alenquer était
pris de la botte on viole la norme viole
Comme ça tu vas me tuer
l'école ne contenait pas la fille brésilienne
Je pleure aussi, le combat se passe bien
monde ici du google deca bien chanter
est également en tête du classement
J'ai déjà parlé au marché, c'était ok, ce n'était pas
merveilleux est merveilleux elle viole
a sauté de la drogue dans une valise
viana ne joue pas longtemps alors tu le feras
ombre
viens avec moi récession
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le premier choc seulement la discothèque 11 chopp
bar rock toute l'heure est fan de six
heures si n'importe quand
Je suis un dessinateur et tout le monde ici à
[ __ ] je sais comment tout va bien je
j'ai plié c'est bon il y a du vent
c'est embrassé la vie telle qu'elle est k c'est ok c'est na
la pirogue est magnifique il est 9 heures quelque chose de nouveau
et le nouveau retour est merveilleux
Je ne suis pas venu pour être un homme partant
message d'amour mais la martre est un
La folie brésilienne et le désordre avec mon
mari prendra teixeira il est ici
Ce n'est pas mon devoir ici avec moi, ne viens pas jouer
avec moi parce que je suis brésilien
prend aussi bien soin du bien commun ici
ça devrait bien fermer moi aussi je ne viens jamais
c'est ok tout le monde vichai la vie telle qu'elle est
d'accord
alors c'est merveilleux c'est merveilleux c'est
un gangster écoute de la bossa bomb à new york
ne combats pas l'homme mossoul
avec caroline mec
snow campbell croit qu'obama va
se lancer dans le différend entre le mexique et
[Applaudissements]